is the Mandalorian season 3 the worst
thing to happen to Star Wars since sand
[Music]
up until yesterday I had not seen a
single episode of the season but
everything that popped up on my Twitter
timeline indicated that it was an
absolute dumpster fire also lizzo's in
it right
[Laughter]
so I wanted to separate the genuine
criticisms of the season from the ones
that are done in bad faith is this
really a god-awful mess that some will
lead you to believe or like Anakin can
this season be redeemed I'll leave time
stamps to all the criticisms in the
description below and while you're at it
be sure to like And subscribe number one
the story's slow and a bit of a mess now
one of the main criticisms I've seen of
the season is that it's straight up
boring when someone says a movie or show
is boring it often boils down to one
thing the pacing of the plot and I do
think this is a genuine criticism for a
number of reasons first plot is driven
by our main characters wanting something
din jarin starts the season by wanting
to redeem himself for taking off his
helmet a big No-No in the ways of the
Mandalore but unfortunately this want
isn't accompanied by high enough Stakes
if dinjaran doesn't bathe himself in the
Living Waters under the minds of
Mandalore his life will pretty much
return to what it's always been so
already we have a weak main goal for our
character second din basically
accomplishes his goal by the end of
episode 2 and it isn't until the end of
episode 5 three episodes later that a
new goal is created the unification of
the Mandalorian people but this goal
isn't given to din it's given to Bo
Katan muddying things even further and
adding strength to the argument that
this season isn't cohesive is season 3
din jaron's story or is it Bo katans to
make matters worse subplots often
overtake the main story multiple times
throughout the season and sometimes
these subplots have zero impact on the
main story take for example Dr
pershing's subplot in episode 3. other
than introducing Ilya Kane who will
later find out is working for moth
guinean you could take out this entire
story and it wouldn't have any impact on
din jaron's Quest and this subplot takes
up the majority of that episode it would
be like watching an episode of Breaking
Bad but instead of following Walter
four-fifths of the episode we'd be
following Skyler around as she takes
Walt Jr to school and goes grocery
shopping now I can forgive some filler
almost every television series does it
but when you combine multiple Filler
episodes such as Boca tan and din
jaron's foray into Placer 15 in episode
6 with weak to no Stakes you get a
combination of a slow plot and the lack
of a cohesive story so for criticism
number one I absolutely think it is well
founded number two where the villains at
I gotta say I love moff Gideon as a
villain Giancarlo Esposito just kills
every role he's in and yet he's
completely squandered this season by
only being in the last two episodes
which and this may just be a coincidence
are currently the two highest rated
episodes of the season if I were to
rewrite this season I'd want to show
moth's extraction from the new Republic
prison transport I'd show him working
with Ilya Kane and I'd want to see him
testing out these Force powers on his
genetically altered clones I'm not
saying he has to be a huge presence
throughout the season just one or two
scenes and episodes so that is
overbearing threat looms above din jarin
at his quest test now this isn't to say
there aren't any villains throughout the
season there's chitters beneath the
minds of Mandalore the pirate Captain
gorion chant and commissioner Hellgate
but these are more one-off villains that
don't have the weight and therefore
Stakes to keep me invested so I
wholeheartedly agree that the lack of a
villain throughout the season's entirety
is a well-founded criticism number three
the weaklorian another criticism I've
seen pop up is that din jarn is
incredibly weak and often needs to be
rescued by characters who are supposed
to be weaker than him to start I counted
the number of times din is captured and
who he saved by to give us a better
understanding whether this criticism is
founded throughout the season I counted
six times twice in episode 2 by Bo Katan
once from chitters and the second as he
falls into the Living Waters and four
times in episode eight one by grogu
after being captured by MAF Gideon grogu
again from the praetorian guards another
by Bo Katan from off Gideon and finally
by grogu from the fiery blast of the
Imperial crew Cruiser now I actually
didn't see this as too big of a problem
partly because it's counterbalance was
scenes where we see how heroic he is I
also don't mind our main character
screwing up or getting caught from time
to time it proves he's human and many
characters throughout Star Wars get
caught or make dumb mistakes so I'm more
willing to forgive this in the grand
scheme of things I think this is a
fairly weak argument but what isn't weak
is our next criticism number four no
character Arc while din does go through
a physical Journey traveling from place
to place what's missing is his own
personal Journey this is that part of
the journey that we the viewer gets us
emotionally involved and care about his
character this is called character Arc
and in season 3 ninjars is almost
non-existent to give you an example
let's contrast this to his much more
powerful Arc in season 1 where he starts
off seeing grogu as just a cash grab
eventually learning to care for him and
risk his life in order to save him you
can track his Arc throughout the season
as he bonds closer with grogu and
eventually makes the the decision to
protect him even if it means having to
sacrifice his life contrast this to
season three how does din John's
character change from the first episode
to the last and I would argue that it
doesn't I mean he does end up officially
adopting grogu but we all kind of knew
that was going to happen and he never
had any inner turmoil about making this
decision in season three so no character
journey is definitely a valid criticism
number five the cameos suck this season
is no stranger to guest cameos we have
Ahmad Bess the actor who played Jar Jar
Binks Star as Jedi Keller and Beck Tim
Meadows as New Republic Colonel Tuttle
and lizzo and Jack Black as these kind
of Royal slash elected officials cameos
have a long history in Star Wars and
Ahmed best appearance in episode 4 was
received very positively so the problem
here isn't the cameos themselves the
lowest rated episode this season is
lizos and Jack blocks episode 6. and I'm
gonna go out on a limb here that if
lizzo weren't in this episode it
wouldn't have received as much backlash
now don't get me wrong here this episode
still sucks it really doesn't Advance a
plot it feels like filler and lizzo's
acting and dialogue are cringe but it's
far easier to scapegoat her than to
critique the minutia of story structure
you add this to the fact that lizzo is a
quote-unquote woke Warrior who advocates
for fat acceptance and trans rights you
create a powder keg for the current
culture War I highly doubt that Matt
Walsh would be doing a piece called Star
Wars is garbage if lizzo weren't in this
episode so to break it down cameos
aren't the big problem here the writing
is number six was the dark saber
meaningless I think it's safe to say
that the darksaber is a MacGuffin an
item that drives the plot forward but
ultimately is unimportant to the story's
resolution perhaps that's why it's
destroyed at the end of the season now
this isn't to say that it's entirely
meaningless it did help us get to where
we are in the story however what we
didn't get was any closure on how its
destruction will lead the mandalorians
to accept a leader who doesn't wield it
we've already seen how the armor one of
the ways most stalwart Defenders allows
Bo Katan to take off her helmet and not
be ostracized it looks as though if the
mandalorians are to rebuild Mandalore
some sort of compromise will need to be
reached on their customs and traditions
which then calls into question whether
the leader of Mandalore has to wield the
darksaber at all we do see the great
Forge re-lit at the end of the season so
maybe it can be restored all in all
calling the darksaber meaningless isn't
the strongest of criticisms however I'll
admit that it definitely wasn't used to
its fullest potential so was this season
bad well I certainly thought it was the
weakest of the three so far but it still
had some enjoyable moments if it can
have a more focused story I think they
can turn season 4 into something really
special and that's it for this video but
I want to hear your criticisms you
thought plagued the Mandalorian thanks
for watching please make sure to like
And subscribe and for more bad takes you
can follow me on Twitter and Instagram
at thinkstory yd until next time
remember
foreign